この後僕の髪型は
こういう前髪にしたいですここが短くてウオッチがすごい長くて目が片方が隠れてる
つかため隠したいんだよねちょっとかっこいい気がしちゃう
中二病とか言うんじゃないよこれじゃあ肇社長です皆が斎藤さんというアプリご存知
でしょうか
けっこう昔ねめちゃくちゃ流行ってたんですけども最近はどうなるかな斎藤さんという
アプリはですね違うに無料で誰とでも電話ができるという訳でございますパッド地区と
怖いですね
もう向かせ使ったからなぁみんなし
てと思うんですけど何からをできるぞせず今今回はの斉藤さんやっていこうと思います
で今回この斎藤さんを使って何をしようかと言いますと僕ないが声が特徴的じゃない
ですか
なんか-雲ねしたら彼もない声変わり失敗したような感じで果たして斉藤さんのやって
みると肇社長とバレるのかどうかっていうのをちょっとやってみたらいいと思います
あー溶け込み様なんではポケッコミュ障
ですねテンション高いときはて付いてるんですけど基本的に人見知りしちゃうんで
ちょっとも斎藤さんを使って僕の人見知りを直すのも含めて僕の声で始めたちょっと
バレるのかどうかっていうの方がやっていこうと思いますなんかね偽物が多いかもしれ
ないからもう今回発見はじめ冊っていう名前でもいけます
いくぜひっん
出会いは求めてないんですよ純粋に本当に話したいだけなんで斉藤さんと華
[音楽]
ああああああああもしもしこんにちはエー
いい天気ですね
あ
やっほぉ
グループブリッジ本当にことで無理どんなポッだね今日は
ぽいねーもしもしーねぇ a & g お疲れ様です
おもしろ朝お疲れ様ですあーもしもし聞こえてますか
あー肇社長ですこんにちは
[音楽]
いい干せますしあとまま
はず3冊をであー
ふーん本当に触れない始めて言ったらダメだ0せようと思ってないなもしもし
あ今は今日は増え声がダサいからなきゃ抱いたバレないですね今日は
なんでわかったのなんでわかったの
本物本物
いやほんと今どこまで真面目しますねほんとほんとあるねっ
でぜ本能の方ものっ
ear
ここへざっくりじゃんトマム山またねありがとね愛を安に入っ
いい人だった普段何か他の生物で斉藤さん楽しいね1回ぷ疑われます本物かどうかって
いう
こんにちはエー
今ですねど嘘じゃんあまず1本
こんにちは楽しめますあ
香港こんばんは
2人いるのからこんにちは
になった
あのあの肇社長って言うんですけど
[音楽]
はぁ
やっぱり半々ですな
みんなにっ
なっちゃん泣かないで今僕学校なる学校にいるの
妻えません
ああこんにちは
あ私はじめシャツをと申しますはいよろしくお願いします肇社長ってご存知ですか
そうなんですよ
今でですねちょっと動画撮ってるんですけど youtube 見られますか
おっと築くため見られますか
まずのせ
ドローンも女性こんにちは
私はず社長と申しますん
はじめましてよろしくお願いします
始め冊でご存知ですか
あそうそうなんですよよくわかりましたね見たことありますか
[音楽]
またよかったら見てくださいね
はい
こんにちは
家の俺もしもしバーン聞こえますか
暗黙肇社長ですねっ
絵本ものですよ
なんだっ派
はっはっはこんにちははじめしたつだと思いますか
brm ペン
あああああ
やっぴをこんにちは
じゃああーあはじめましてはずに社長と申しますえっ
本当ですよわかりますこれ
本物ですよあ理由
はい本当ですよこんにちは
ああああ
amaran
姉さん姉じゃあ俺はい
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ